2013 و 2014 أبرمت لافارج صفقة مع
الشيطان ، اعترفت البارجة في فرعها السوري
بالتورط في
سلوك إجرامي يشكل
دعمًا ماديًا للإرهاب من الناحيتين القانونية والعملية
[موسيقى]
في أغسطس 2013 وأكتوبر 2014
استفادت لافارج من قبضة الدولة الإسلامية الحديدية
والسيطرة العنيفة على سوريا
لخنق منافستها وزيادة
حصتها في السوق
[موسيقى]
أخفت لافارج أيضًا شراكتها مع
هؤلاء الإرهابيين من خلال شبكة من
العقود المزيفة فواتير مزيفة
وسطاء فاسدون وحسابات بريد إلكتروني خارج النظام
[موسيقى]
الإقرار بالذنب اليوم بتهم الإرهاب من
قبل شركة البناء متعددة
الجنسيات LaFarge وفرعها السوري
يعكس جرائم الشركات
التي وصلت إلى مستوى منخفض جديد ومكان مظلم للغاية
اتهمته وزارة العدل
بتقديم الدعم المادي
لمنظمات إرهابية أجنبية
[موسيقى]